hi and welcome to serverless migration
station a serverless Expeditions
mini-series focus on helping developers
modernize their app to using the latest
features on one of our serverless
compete platforms today my colleague
Martin and I will hop on our little
friend part of the train to continue our
journey migrating from the app engine
user service to Cloud identity platform
sounds great and as always I'm happy to
be here Wes last time in module 20 we
gave the module 1 sample app the ability
to sign in and out users with the user
service what are we doing today
that's right Martin for those who
haven't seen the module 20 video or
completed its code lab links are
available down in the description below
pause here to check them out because we
start from the module 20 app this module
21 video is about switching from the
user's API to Cloud identity platform to
manage users sounds a little too easy
every time we do one of these migrations
it's usually more than just the one
advertised what else are we doing today
Wes I'm not getting away with it this
time aren't I alright we're repeating
the model 2 migration from App engine
NDB to Cloud NDB and upgrading to python
3. okay that sounds doesn't sound too
bad actually wait wait I wasn't done yet
while it's true that there are no
additional migrations there's a little
bit of extra work the user's API has
built-in support for app engine admin
users but not identity platform so we
have to build that functionality so that
it matches how the user's API Works what
do you mean by admin users here you mean
giving people access to my cloud project
because that sounds like a security
issue no no no I met admins of just your
app not your Cloud project an admin of
your app doesn't mean they have elevated
access in your project unless you give
it to them say if there are also a
developer of your app okay that was good
I was just a bit confused about what
admin meant here
yeah it's just an arbitrary title and
could just mean such users have extra
functionality in your app but it's
completely independent of whether
they're admins of any of your Cloud
projects we covered admins a little bit
more in module 20 so go back and check
it out for more details got it I suppose
admin is an overloaded term so thanks
for that uh maybe we should come up with
a new term
now back on topic since there's so much
happening today I don't want to focus on
things we're already done like the ndbe
migration
can you point our viewers to where they
can find out more about that migration
understood well stay focused on the
identity platform migration but keeping
mention of NDB to a minimum you can find
out all about the cloud NAB migration in
the module 2 video and codelab which are
linked below cool now what does a
migration to Identity platform look like
it's quite different from the app engine
users API isn't it
yep it's different use this as a purely
app Engine Solution while identity
platform is based on Firebase auth which
has many features on its own like
support for email password and phone
authentication as well as Federated
identity provider integration and other
features you see listed here down below
we'll link you to an overview page where
you can learn more about Firebase auth
features
Federated identity provider integration
it's a mouthful but it also sounds kind
of interesting what does it actually
mean Wes
well first what if every app you make
that has users requires you to build yet
on other email password authentication
system crazy right and it's not even
related to the services you're providing
so identity provider integration means
that you can just use Firebase auth as
your ad for indication solution for all
of your apps it supports signing with
email and password phone and email links
furthermore Firebase auth supports
Federated identity providers so users
can sign in with the ones listed here uh
wait does this mean that I no longer
have to require all my users to have
Gmail or Google accounts
that's right sign in with all those
providers also comes with Firebase auth
and there's a pretty nice UI component
you can just drop into your code today I
am sold on Firebase off it's very
awesome I'm wondering what else identity
platform can do to make it even more
amazing
yeah I know it's hard to top Firebase
off right well let's give it a try so
identity platform takes all that's
available in Firebase auth and adds a
number of Enterprise features to it like
multi-factor authentication oidc and
saml SSO support multi-tenancy 99.95 SLA
and more link below is a page that
compares features of both products I
didn't think it was possible but those
are great additional features way more
than you can get from App engine's old
user service
uh so how else is identity platform
different from that Old user service
good question features aside the biggest
difference is where the authentication
code is located the user service runs in
your app engine app code code that lives
on serverless platforms like app engine
or server full platforms like gke are
managed kubernetes service or Plano
compute engine VMS is considered
server-side if the auth code lives there
that means there's going to be a round
trip to the server for every sign in and
sign out now contrast that with identity
platform Firebase auth where the
authentication code is in the web page
users see on screen that's client side
because the Computing logic is
downloaded with a client HTML now that
we know the difference let's compare
module 20's sample app versus module 21s
uh-huh I think I understand now it looks
like the module 20 app has to connect to
app engine to access the user service
server side for signing in and out with
Google sign in but the module 21 app
uses the identity platform code embedded
in my client side HTML and JavaScript so
it doesn't call app engine the server to
do anything right
exactly this means that our app is more
correct because as a user I shouldn't be
triggering two visits when I hit at the
app and then log in and yep it generally
doesn't require calling the server ah I
didn't realize that uh yeah it seems
like calling server twice would be
inefficient
um and what do you mean when you said
the auth process doesn't generally
require hitting the server
man nothing escapes you does it well
okay if all we need to do is swap user
off the client side then we'd be done
right however as we mentioned earlier we
need to check whether a user who has
just signed in is an admin or not and
that does require a quick ping to the
server for a quick yes no answer got it
anything else to be aware of
well because we're using new cloud
services they have to be enabled first
can't run any code without doing that
yeah that makes sense so what are we
enabling and how do we do it
the new Services we're using are cloud
datastore cloud resource manager and
Cloud identity platform the first pair
are apis so you can enable those from
either the API manager in the cloud
console or from the command line using
the gcloud services enable command and
what about identity platform isn't that
the most important service to enable
that is the main migration we're doing
today after all
yep that's right identity platform is a
bit unique in that it's not enabled in
the API manager but in the cloud
Marketplace it's really more of a
service than an API and at this time
Marketplace Services can only be enabled
in the cloud console
that was a lot uh can you summarize this
migration at a high level for everybody
sure we're migrating from the app engine
user service to Identity platform which
is enabled in the cloud Marketplace
identity platform has a few extra steps
we'll cover during the migration so stay
tuned for that to mimic the user's api's
ability to recognize admin users we need
to enable and use the cloud resource
manager API we're repeating the module 2
migration from App engine NDB to Cloud
NDB and Reporting the app from python3
and then maybe if you have to we'll
backport it to python 2 but more on that
later okay there's a lot going on here
so so that summary was really helpful
right I'm ready to move to Identity
platform now
great we'll start with the module 20
code and finish with one of the module
21 folders pause if you need to find
your module 20 code or copying it from
the repo here and below are the links to
the repo and the code lab ready let's go
to the computer and do this migration
for each migration let's ensure we're
starting with a working app in this case
the model 20 sample go to the folder
where your code is and delete the lib
folder if you have one run the PIP
install command to install the
third-party packages into lib python 2
developers know that self bundling like
this is required by app engine and one
big benefit of upgrading to Python 3 is
that you no longer have to do this now
deploy to the cloud using the gcloud app
deploy command the app should show the
most recent visits as well as allow for
user logins including recognizing admin
users now that we have a working app we
can replace its use of the users API
with Cloud identity platform porting
python two apps to Python 3 is something
that most of you will likely be doing so
that's what we're doing as well if for
some reason you have to stay on python 2
the colab provides details on how to
backport the module 21 Python 3 app back
to python 2 but we won't cover it here
the first step is to enable all the new
services for the module 21 app earlier
Martin and I discuss how you can enable
apis from the cloud console go to the
API manager and enable cloud datastore
and Cloud resource manager apis
alternatively enable both of them from
the command line the final service to
enable is identity platform which
requires you to do it from the cloud
Marketplace in the cloud console after
you've enabled it there are two more
steps as part of its setup first because
Firebase auth supports so many auth
providers like sign in with Twitter and
Facebook you have to choose which ones
you want to use for your apps the app
engine user service only supports Google
sign-in so that's the only one we enable
in this codelab the next step is to
click on application setup details from
the web tab of the resulting dialog copy
the API key and off domain fields from
the config variable we're going to drop
those two into our web template in a
minute the codelab has all the details
so be sure to check it out app engine
config.py and the lib folder aren't used
in the Python 3 runtime so delete them
the module 20 requirements.txt file
listed only flask
for additional third-party libraries
required for module 21 we're going to
add the cloud authentication Library the
cloud NDB and resource manager client
libraries and also the Firebase admin
SDK for app.yaml delete everything
except for the runtime directive
changing it to a supported Python 3
version today that would be 3.9 or 310.
at the top replace the Imports of app
engine NDB end users with Cloud NDB and
resource manager also add a new import
of the Firebase admin SDK in addition to
initializing flask create a new
datastore client as Cloud apis generally
require a client object since we're only
going to use the resource manager API
once we're creating its client elsewhere
so stay tuned for that next we're adding
new code to support user admin
validation the user's API has built-in
support for recognizing admins but
identity platform isn't an app engine
product so we need to build this missing
functionality we also don't use the
Firebase auth custom claims technique
for recognizing admin users because that
requires our app to manage who the
admins are so instead we're doing it the
way that the user's API does it the get
GAE admins function uses the resource
manager API to fetch the IAM allow
policy it collates and Returns the
complete set of all admin users based on
their epigen roles later on you'll see
we call this function once and cache
that set of admin users the next
function we're adding is is admin when a
user signs in with Firebase auth the
client side calls this function passing
in the logged in user's ID token once
the ID token is verified the user's
email address is extracted to see if
they are in the set of admin users the
yes no answer returned helps the client
determine whether to show the admin user
badge in the UI the last code snippet to
add are two lines to initialize Firebase
auth as well as to call get GAE admins
to Cache the set of admin users creating
new visits and querying the most recent
visits don't really change the only
difference is due to Cloud NAB requiring
use of its python context manager when
making data store calls so you see new
with blocks encapsulating those calls in
store visit and fetch visits this is
identical to the module 2 migration the
user service is a server-light solution
and its use in the main Handler
supporting user management is replaced
by identity platforms client-side
solution this means deleting all of the
user management code from the app and
reverting it back to the main Handler
all the way back to module 1. all of the
functionality removed will be added back
on the client side in the web template
and here it comes starting with the
required Firebase Imports followed by
the app config earlier we copy the API
key and auth domain from the identity
platform applications setup details
dialog and this is where you add both
values that's followed by initializing
Firebase and Firebase auth finally
implement the login and logout functions
for the button button in the UI moving
down the last new piece to add is the
callback for when the auth state changes
meaning when a user signs in or out if
logging in display the user email at the
top flip the button to logout and call
is admin on the server to see whether to
show the admin user badge or not on the
flip side if logging out replace the
user's email address with the generic
user remove the admin user badge if
there and flip the button back to login
the remaining changes Implement
replacing the values from the user
service to those from Identity platform
and that's it as far as updating the
code goes now let's confirm that the new
model 21 app works first be sure you've
completed the following enabled the
cloud datastore and resource manager
apis plus the identity platform enable
at least one Firebase auth provider for
example Google sign in configure fired
base with the API key and off domain
variables in index.html deleted the lib
folder and app engine config.py if you
have already
now run gcloud app deploy and then visit
the app on App engine you should see the
same UI as the model 20 app the most
recent visits with user login
functionality at the top click the login
button what happens next depends on how
many users are registered with your web
browser if you have no users registered
with your browser or one or more but
none are logged in you get the expected
Google sign-in dialog if you already
have one user already signed in the
pop-up immediately disappears leaving
you in a logged in state if the user
isn't an admin you should just see their
email at the top with a logout button
but if the user is an admin you should
also see the user's email plus the log a
button but in between is the admin user
badge if you have multiple users
registered with your browser you'll see
the account picker from which you choose
an account to log in s if they're
already signed in you won't be prompted
for a password and you get the
appropriate admin or non-admin screen we
just mentioned congrats for successfully
migrating from App engine users to the
identity platform wow that was a pretty
big update us I'm happy we even fixed
the bug we're signing in now doesn't
result in yet another visit uh to the
server
and we completely changed out the user
management system switch from server
side to client-side and build our own
admin user validation
there must be a lot of documentation to
read for all this could you point us to
it
sure all of the product documentation
you see here are linked below we've also
included an IEM overview page so you can
learn more about roles and allow
policies great thanks for all that for
our viewers to check out uh now that we
successfully migrated to Identity
platform what other migrations should I
consider
great question and a couple come to mind
before this migration we introduce how
to use the user service which was
covered last time in module 20. app
engine also has task queues learn about
migrating push tasks to Cloud tasks in
module 789 for migrating pull tests to
Cloud Pub sub see modules 18 and 19. we
also migrated from App engine NDB to
Cloud NDB here so review the module 2
for more details we couldn't cover today
if your app uses app engine memcache
consider migrating to Cloud memory store
that's covered in modules 12 and 13. if
your app uses app engine blob store
consider migrating to cloud storage and
see modules 15 and 16. if you want to
upgrade to Python 3 but stay using App
engine bundle Services see module 17.
those running small app engine apps or
who want to break up large monoliths can
consider Cloud functions covered in
module 11. finally if containerization
is now part of your software development
workflow you can migrate to Cloud run
module 4 is for Docker users while
module 5 is for those who are new to
Containers or don't want to do Docker
Docker files or even think about
containers and we look forward to having
you join us on any of those Journeys
this is Wesley on behalf of Martin and
Porter and we'll see you on another
serverless Expedition soon in the
meantime happy travels
[Music]